Try My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
I mean you're,
you're seeing all these new
approaches constantly changing.
So many great minds involved.
Yeah,
that's what I liked.
I mean fear us a hobby and I
meet them on the list can go on,
but that's what,
to me,
that's what I've become now a bit of
more of a nerd because you call somebody
fights and you,
you try to have a life as well,
but I'm really now getting back into,
okay,
let's catch up and see what
these different minds are saying.
Well you yourself sir,
even you know,
listening to this,
it's just always so cool to hear
different perspectives and okay,
what's going to work.
It's super important for all of us.
I think that's why Bj's going to do good.
It really,
I truly believe because he changed cab.
I think talent,
like Bj in his training in Hawaii,
you know,
he kind of dictates
whatever he wants to do.
He's so talented.
He schools people around.
And that's why when you put
people like that on a pressure,
they get tired because they
never experienced that in
the ring because he's so
way ahead above of everybody else.
So if they want to do extra three rounds
with them and he doesn't want to do it,
he's going to have,
I'm not going to do it.
I think that's a batch of
that trick at Greg Winkle.
John,
you know,
and there he's got all
these guys gunning for him.
It's a legend.
I mean I'm,
I can only imagine the sparring
sessions they have going on.
I think it's going to
do really well for him.
It's opponent.
Yeah.
Rodriguez is really good.
Okay.
But I think the whole,
honestly,
I mean the,
he's a hall of Famer,
done everything of w we
saw against Frankie Edgar.
What does it,
we talked about our podcast the last,
when was Matt Hughes?
2010 do you,
why do you think he's still fighting?
Well,
he probably feels like
he didn't do it right.
He probably feels like the
fights he took with Frankie.
We had that really bizarre standups
stance was that was the weirdest thing guy
I've ever seen.
He decided that he was gonna fight that
way because it was more efficient and it
didn't use as much energy
as like widening his stance.
And He,
I think a lot of his career
he was concerned with losing
his energy in the ring.
Yup.
A lot of his crew,
he's worried about gassing him.
So then he went with Mark Marinovich.
Right.
So he does these two camps with Marvin
or intervention at least two camps.
Correct?
He did Sean Sherk and I
think he did Diego Sanchez.
I know he did.
Diego Sanchez.
Yeah cause I know also that Steve Maxwell
was training Diego Sanchez got Sanchez
and incredible shame.
But that was Bj in his prime and when
Bj wasn't tired when he was in shape and
he was joking around about it.
Like when I have a six pack,
oh my aunt took him know what was it?
He wasn't just a different
animal back then,
but it was only sustainable
for like a few fights.
I think like Bj,
it's for whatever reason,
it was hard for him to get totally
motivated to get into that kind of shape
again.
And you know,
when he described it,
it sounded helacious like he
couldn't hold his daughter literally,
literally so tired after working out
that he couldn't even hold his kid.
And they have a very specific training
philosophy to the Marinovich is,
and uh,
in a lot of ways,
um,
uh,
some of the guys that,
like nick curse on who trains under
his philosophy and a speed of sport in
California,
they want strength and conditioning
to be number one priority number one,
you already know how to fight.
I love that.
Yeah.
And the idea is that you
already know how to find,
so since [inaudible] how to fight,
you should just work on having the most
incredible aerobic threshold that goes
back to frank and a plan to Ortiz.
Well,
yeah,
but even Franco with the,
why am I going to Kip Maury Smith with
a node deck partner show you at the
beginning,
that's what frank was all about was the,
the couldn't be cardio.
Cardio was on the bus back.
Uh,
when Tito loss to frank,
I was in the same bus going
back to the airport at Tito,
jump next to me and he starts asking me
question about stamina because I always
said is the most important thing
you can never have enough stamina.
Right.
The most important that you start asking
drills and doing the all these things.
And then he became debt.
Crazy cycle,
cardio,
you know.
And he started beating everybody,
showing me,
transferred that to Kendall Grove and
trained under the ultimate fighter when
Kendell came out of that show.
And that's what he told me.
He's like,
it's all cardio man.
Everything is about cardio and but again,
cardio also.
What about the nerves then in
how much panicking and your,
your emotions drained?
Like what I'm saying is a factor in it,
but the actual real cold hard
cardio plays a factor too.
Right.
And it also plays a factor in your nerves.
Yeah.
Because if you know that you have a small
gas tank and they started to give it
up.
Yeah.
And especially when you walk to the ring.
Did I train hard enough?
You know,
cause you know that you can really go,
you know,
after work I done,
we'll do seven,
six minutes round.
So the type at full blast,
that's like 42 minutes.
Wow.
Uh,
and but that was after a workout.
But I knew that nobody did that.
So I was not going to run out against,
because we had half our fights in the,
in Japan.
But it's the only way to do it.
Chances are they go hard.
And I had guys coming who couldn't
do the warmup in my class.
This is a 20 minute warmup is the boss
where workout with the sprawls and in a
minutes we built,
I fill them up with the IDA pushups
or with the Kettlebell swings.
So it's 20 minutes straight.
People come in who had a fight like in
two weeks in Japan and he couldn't do it.
They had dead man.
I said,
don't fight.
He said,
what do you mean?
I said,
this is the warmup.
We didn't even start now and neutral.
So say they lost because
of cardio over there,
but he's not shy.
But how do you do this?
I said,
it's just baby steps.
It is just get yourself to the point
where you can get through that entire warm
up,
full clip and then just get,
yeah,
just keep doing it.
Yeah.
Okay.